so I'm going to talk about individuals
with recent HIV infection today and I'm
going to tell you about some data from
five years of a cohort that was done I'm
in Southern California and then I'm
going to show you some new data from a
new cohort that I have also on recently
infected men and so the new data i'll
show you at the end describes the new
study i'm doing we just finished our
first year of data collection so you're
going to see hot off the press brand new
data from our first year which we're
really excited about and the one thing
I'll tell you ahead of time is that the
new study I'm doing we've actually
captured a slightly different population
than the men that we studied in the
previous five years which I am excited
about because they tend to be a lot
younger than we expected so that's
something new so why study people with
recent HIV infection well this year for
anyone who went to the CDC 2010 STD
prevention conference one of the things
that was the big news was that the rate
of new HIV diagnoses among MSM men who
have sex with men was reported to be
more than forty four times that of other
men and more than 40 times that of women
so these really are in the United States
a big part of our epidemic and actually
we're learning in a lot of other
countries in the world as the data is
growing a big part of the HIV epidemic
now the range of new HIV diagnosis that
the CDC just reported was 522 to 989
cases per 100,000 MSM and that's
compared to 12 per 100,000 of other men
and 13 / 100 and thousand women and this
is based on the 2007 US surveillance
data the high incidence this suggests
that we still have a high incidence of
HIV among MSM in the US and in fact in
the 2006 data we saw that a third of
adults that were newly diagnosed could
were considered to have recent HIV
infection so that was about 500 sorry
about 56,000 new infections in the US
that year so there's a lot of people
with recent infection in the United
States so why have cohorts with recent
affection why do we care about this well
some of the mathematical models that
have been done have suggested that a lot
of the HIV transmission occurs during
this period of new infection in fact
some of the estimates are between 25 and
forty-seven percent and that's because
people at that period of time tend to
have a high viral load they also tend to
not yet be on treatment or not yet have
controlled virus and they also sometimes
are in a period of time where they're
still practicing the risky behaviors
that's how they got HIV so they were
practicing risk and that's how they
acquired infection and then because they
continued to practice risk that's still
how they can transmit infection so why
do cohorts is because at baseline when
we study people with new infection when
we first identify them we're really
looking at the factors that are the risk
for acquisition but as we follow people
over time we then are really looking at
the risks for transmission as I
mentioned as these are people who are
highly infectious and also we're still
probably practicing risky behavior so
follow-up reveals a lot about how
secondary transmission occurs who
infects who and why and this data is
really essential for prevention
interventions
so I'm going to talk to you about some
behavior change that we saw in the
eighth or cohort which was the cute and
early disease research program that was
a nih funded multi-site program of which
southern california was the site san
diego and los angeles i'm going to show
you some work we did with behaviors over
time of the Southern Californian men
there also some look we did at the
baseline of people with acquired a our
view resistant virus and behaviors and
then talk about measuring following up
and recruiting individuals with recent
infection and their sexual partners in
the new study that I'm doing and then a
specimen repository that we formed and
some opportunities for collaboration
there so first let's start talking about
this a drip cohort so basically this was
a clinical study that was a when I
joined with a team and had been going
ready for five years where they were
trying to study people with recent
infection and we added on a behavioral
component to it and this is an important
thing to understand is that this was a
clinical study that had a behavioral
component added so it wasn't designed
initially as a behavioral study so
because of that you know as you'll see
in this we had a pretty significant loss
to follow-up for the behavioral
component because it was an add-on it
wasn't initial sort of primary aim of
the study nevertheless we have people
that were followed up to three and a
half years but most complete data is on
those that were involved in the cohort
for just 12 months everyone in the first
year that they were involved was
re-interviewed or offered to
re-interview every three months in the
first year and then after that year
every six months after and we had
detailed behavioral data collected by a
cozzy and follow-up behavioral data is
available on 193 of the men that we
enrolled because not all of the 225
completed follow-up interviews and these
193 men over a year of involvement in
the study because i am looking i took a
piece of the data of just those that
were involved for a year reported on a
thousand and eleven partners
per participant there was about a median
of two follow-up interviews conducted
over a median follow-up time of 106 days
in a total of five hundred and sixty-two
follow-up interviews so the first thing
we did was look at what happened in the
first three months the really early time
right around diagnosis and when we took
a look at the first three months at the
first interview a follow-up interview
that people were done one of the first
things we saw was that the probability
of you a I was much higher for people
with the main partner than with any
other type of partner so if I can figure
out which is the pointer here so here's
the main partner and these are the odds
ratios and the confidence intervals for
any other type of partner okay so people
were much more likely to have you a I
with a main partner than any other
partner now we've seen this before in
the literature people are more intimate
with main partners so they have you a I
more with them not really a surprise but
this was a pretty big difference what
was interesting here was then if you
consider the HIV status of the partners
right what do we see well we did see a
big increase at first three months in
what we call zero sorting which is that
more people had and this is uai with
another positive person okay but there
what's interesting is that although
there was a decrease in uai with
negative and partners who were unknown
I've known HIV status we still had quite
a significant amount of you I I
happening with these partners so this
was just the first three months so this
suggested we are seeing a trend in a
drop of risk behavior we're seeing more
Sierra sorting we're seeing a lot of
risks still within main partnerships so
then we decided to look over time at
what happened in the rest of the cohort
after the three months and one of the
things we wanted to look at was just
sort of take a general cut of what is
the overall pattern of partnering that
we see among these men so one of the
things we saw was about twenty two
percent of people started and they had a
main partner at baseline but then did
not have another main partner continuing
partner throughout the rest of the time
people really divided up
across these patterns almost pretty
evenly we had a third of people that had
a main partner at baseline and then had
a continuing partner at some point
during the year not necessarily the same
but at least they had some sort of
ongoing relationship some people had no
partner about another third had no
partner main partner baseline and never
had a main partner in the entire year
and then we had the smallest percent
about seventeen percent who did not have
a main partner baseline when they
acquired HIV but then during the year
got a main partner form domain
partnership and had an ongoing
partnership at some point so we see
pretty even split in the patterns over
time people are sort of all over the
place there's not a clear thing that
most people tend to form a partner or
lose a partner but what did they do in
general in terms of just the number of
people they were having sex with
remember because those were sort of
persistent partnerships or partnerships
that go on this is just the raw number
of partners reported in the three month
period before any particular interview
and one of the things we do see when you
look over a year is a significant drop
so that means over time people are
having total numbers of partners that
are less so they go from 8.8 mean
partners in the previous three months
when around the time that they Siro
converted to after a year about 5.8
partners now that's pretty impressive
drop however you could say you know
that's not exactly a tiny number you
know 5.8 mean partners after about a
year you know they're still pretty
sexually active there so we see a trend
towards reduction in terms of number of
partners but we still see quite a lot of
partners happening and the biggest drop
and I'll come back this a minute we see
is in this first three month period so
right around the time that they were
diagnosed initially there's a big drop
and then it's sort of stabilized as it
continues down a little bit but you can
see it's pretty much leveling off
how about the types of different
partners that they had well from what
you saw in terms of persistent partners
and having an ongoing partner we sort of
assumed they were main partners but
actually we ask people at each interview
to tell us about the type of partner
that they had and we gave them a list of
all these different types so they could
tell us about a main partner and they
all came with definitions they could
have a regular partner which was
somebody that they had sex with on an
ongoing basis but that wasn't
necessarily a main partner a friend
who's somebody that they had social
relationships with as well as sex but
that their main relationship was a
social one but they occasionally had sex
they could have an acquaintance partner
who's somebody that they kind of knew
and then they had sex with a one time
partner which is somebody that just had
sex with once and never again a trade
partner which is somebody they exchanged
drugs or money with for sex or were
given drugs or money for sex and then an
unknown partner which is somebody they
had no name of or no information with so
among these the main thing that you see
here is that this which is the main
partner was most people reported having
a main partner and the proportion of
people with the main partner that was of
the last partners that was a main
partner increased over the year a little
bit in terms of the other types of
partners people pretty much maintain the
same pattern they had at the beginning
so about the same portion of people who
had had an unknown partner or trade
partner when they acquired HIV had it
after 12 months you know there's a
little bit of a drop but it was not
significant so this was the biggest
change was the main part nning and
although it's sort of bouncing around
this is a slight significant increase in
the percent of those who at the end of
12 months have a main partner so how
about some of the other risk behaviors
over the year so what we did here was we
took on the 193 man and the a thousand
and eleven partners they reported on and
this sort of shows what happened to them
over time so of the thousand eleven 597
of them were reported at baseline and
partly that's because we asked them
about three partners at baseline and
because the interview was becoming too
long on follow-up we only ask people
the last partner and then if the last
partner wasn't a main partner also a
main partner so we have less partners
reported on partly because of the design
of the questionnaire but also because we
do have a drop off we started with 193
who reported some partner over time and
we ended up with 55 that we have data on
at the end of 12 months so that was um
some loss to follow-up there in terms of
those who reported any uai with a
partner there is a slight increase so if
baseline about forty five percent
reported any uai where is at the end of
12 months 56% report any UAE but now
that's any uei with anyone and that's a
pretty gross measure so we wanted to
sort of drill down to this and
understand a little bit does that you a
I really mean risk what's really
happening in here and we were interested
in what was really driving the UA I and
what was happening with drug use so
interestingly we do have a slight
decrease in those who report having
using methamphetamines with partners
over time which is the main drug that
was used here and we have a pretty
significant increase down here and those
who reported having an hiv-positive
partner at all so that again this is
pretty good support for a trend toward
zero sorting we had about sixteen
percent with a positive partner at
baseline and by the end of the year we
have about thirty six percent okay so
it's a twenty percent increase so zero
sorting is a little controversial
because the data about zero sorting has
been very mixed sarah sorting suggests
that people pick a partner of the same
status and it usually refers to
hiv-positive people who then choose to
have another HIV positive partner mostly
for the sense of risk reduction and to
be able to have unprotected sex without
a risk of transmission so the question
has been do people who are HIV positive
select other HIV positive people to be
partners so when they look for partners
did they try to find someone who's also
HIV positive and the evidence is mixed
some studies have found that with some
types of partners people are looking for
positive partners and others have found
that they have it so there's a lot sort
of to be learned about this so far
yes
so there is data in the eighth or cohort
and as Simon frosty Sakura is also part
of it knows that the data exists I
didn't have it available for this
analysis so the data is there there was
some effort to recruit some partners and
enroll some I think in total in this
cohort about 55 partners were recruited
at some point there was some matching of
the partner types I think they found a
lot of diversity right that there wasn't
you can't find those metal bars is the
cluster by
by H I just got together and also by
some risk factors that Bethany for
people who methamphetamine users for it
better
yeah Simon actually has that he's that
data has done that analyses so he could
talk about the subtype but yeah I so
that was generally what they found was
it was age and it's interesting in the
relative age clustering so it's there
but it wasn't part of this
right and there was a substudy actually
done in the sober about sort of super
infection as well and there have been a
few cases of super infection identified
think davey smith wrote a paper on that
from this cohort i remember which is
about the same right the incidence of a
chinese
at least during the early parts
no we haven't done that announces to do
what do QA at the end okay sorry okay so
that's all right ok just define you AI
okay I'm sorry in case I didn't you AI
is unprotected anal intercourse okay so
but I'd love to have questions so I'm
happy to have them but I guess we'll
call them for the end so this is now
looking at the trends in unprotected
anal intercourse over time by the HIV
status of the partner so this is really
where you get a sense of transmission
risk and if there is ZERO sorting going
on and so what we've done here and I
have to say this data has been
tremendously resilient because we have a
number of different ways that we asked
about unprotected anal intercourse we
asked about it at the last sex we asked
about it ever we asked about in the past
three months and so this is the most
robust measure we have that really looks
at the recent uai but when we looked at
all the other measures I have to say we
saw the exact same pattern and this is
the pattern that we see the pattern is
that they start off about here that risk
drops at some point early in the year
and then rebounds and this rebound is
pretty significant this rebound is here
is with people with the HIV negative or
unknown partner so this is the
transmission risk here now people with
positive partners who are Sarah sorting
who may have a risk of super infection
but no risk of new transmission actually
have you at about the same level which
is there's no change over the year
that's significant but the transmission
risk here in terms of really secondary
transmission is increasing now there's
only one other paper that's really
looked at people with new diagnosis or
recent infections and followed them over
time and that was some work done san
francisco by grant Colfax in a paper
published in 2002 and their sample size
was a lot smaller but they actually
showed a very similar rebound and that
cohort was followed about 10 years
before this one was so what that
suggests is that we're not doing a very
good job and we haven't improved over
time in terms of working with people
with new diagnosis
those other guys were also in the period
of time where I reviews were really
first being introduced whereas this
cohort was in a period of time where it
was more established although the cohort
ended in 07 still the fact that we're
seeing a same trend in a different era
is a pretty compelling so this is pretty
much I think our I think really big as
finding which is this rebound here that
happens in that it really jumps up here
after nine months
now we did a multivariable analysis and
this is actually not our final model and
we're still playing with it because of
this one we restricted it to only last
partners and we're using less than our
full sample of partners but we have now
reconfigured it and pulled in the new
all the partners and so we'll be able to
redo it in the next couple days but
again we've redone the sample this
analysis in particular here about 10
different times in 10 different ways and
we always find the same thing which is
guess what meth use really drives you AI
well what has bounced around a little
bit in right here is close to
significance but not there but I think
once we pull any other partners will
come out is whether the relational
factors which are measured in this study
by a partnership assessment scale which
measures dynamics of the partnership and
a quantitative measure so that rather
using type of partnership we use a
numeric measure of partnership relate
relation and that has shown us in
previous analyses and I think is going
to come back in here that the more
intimate the partnership the more likely
people are to have you AI and that's
even when you control for HIV status so
I am confident it's going to come back
when we put more of our I think this was
a power issue and I think also our
confidence interval will come down it's
because it's bounced around a bit but
always methamphetamine use is the
driving factor here so again we want to
look a little bit more about that and so
here we looked at just the raw
probability of reporting uai over time
for the methamphetamine users and
non-users and guess what boom the meth
users way up
okay so also we looked at these
relational factors with meth users and
we wanted to know because we did find an
interaction at one point between the
status of the partner and the
partnership assessment scale so we said
so do these guys have less intimate
partnerships well first of all here you
can see the partnership assessment scale
score by types of partners and you can't
read it very well unfortunately
something's going on but this is the
unknown partners have the lowest score
and it goes all the way up to over here
are the main partners who have the
highest mean score what's interesting is
that the trade partners do not have the
lowest score and I think that's because
sometimes people know their trade
partners pretty well so partnership
assessment scale measures things like
how well you know the person how often
you see them how sort of involved you
are in their lives and so people may be
pretty involved in the lives of people
they trade sex with and this actually
was a surprise I expected the trade
partnerships to be sort of more
anonymous and less involved but they
weren't we had a smaller number of them
though so these are our confidence
interval so it's got a pretty wide one
now these are the meth users this is
people who use meth and this is people
who don't use math and so you can see
our hypothesis was right that people who
use math have a lower partnership
assessment scale overall across all
their partnerships than people who don't
use meth so if you're heavily involved
in drugs you're not forming very
intimate partnerships
so what are our conclusions over this
first year that these men with recent
HIV infection did report decreases in
risk behavior and increases in Cyril
sorting sorting and Maine pardoning
during their first year after diagnosis
that there is evidence in a rebound of
risk however after nine months
particularly uai with uninfected
partners or partners of unknown status
and then as I mentioned this is a very
similar to the trend that was reported
by colfax in 02 so we're seeing a
continuation of the same pattern in this
population of MSM and that was also on
the west coast that was in San Francisco
that Matthews clearly remains a driving
force in risk behavior we have seen a
lot of evidence of this for the risk of
acquisition of HIV we know that people
who use math are more likely to get HIV
and now we can see even once infected
people who are meth users are continuing
to have risk and so may be an important
force in driving the continuation of the
epidemic that there are clearly
identified time points for behavioral
interventions for people with this
period of time of new diagnoses those
first three months there seems to be a
lot going on in terms of a change people
do decrease their behavior the problem
is they're having difficulty sustaining
it and so if we don't get in there after
the three months they will rebound and
that future research does need to
consider the HIV care status and viral
loads when analyzing that again that
data exists but is not integrated into
this particular data set and our new
study it is and what that will suggest
is that perhaps some of this is driven
by you know people who had really a
controlled virus and so they felt like
they could practice risk without a lot
of risk of transmission that at this
point we don't know that's not part of
this analysis
so we also did another analysis a couple
years ago I want to share with you on
the baseline data from here I'm not
looking at trends but looking at
resistant virus and behaviors at the
time that we were doing this study some
of you may remember number years ago a
paper came out about math user here in
the region in New York who had multiple
resistant virus and was said to be
methamphetamine user and there's a lot
of concern that there was an association
between Matthews and resistant virus so
we did an analysis to sort of see what
was going on with that and so we here we
took 117 of our sample that we had
complete questionnaires on and also that
we had the serotype had been tested for
genotypic and phenotypic HIV drug
resistance so we only had that full data
on 119 17 of the sample so one of the
things we wanted to look at was all the
behaviors is it the amount of sex is it
the amount of people you have sex with
and because we had a very detailed
questionnaire we were able to explore a
lot of these risks it wasn't the whoops
went the wrong direction was it the
duration of the sexual activity we
actually knew how long the sex lasted
was it the existence of a main partner
in other words repeated sex with the
same person these are some of the things
and then of course the type of substance
so overall when we looked at this subset
we saw that the mean median number of
samples before I showed you the mean was
about eight the median number in the
last 12 months that's over the year was
12 a median total of you AI across the
last three partners was five with a mean
of 47 and this was the range 0 to 500 16
so again this would be the exposure to a
partner 51 percent of our sample overall
reported substance use during sexual
activity in the last 12 months with at
least one of their last three partners
and thirty-five percent reported use
with multiple substances methamphetamine
was our most commonly used drug reported
during sexual activity with the last
three partners thirty-four percent
poor Dave Matthews volatile nitrates was
not far behind twenty-nine percent
marijuana and then GHB 12.5 percent had
a genotypic drug resistance to at least
one class of arvs this is at baseline
when they enrolled and fourteen percent
had phenotypic drug resistance so then
when we put it in the model what we see
and the top here is the genotypic
resistance and we see that here it is
associated this is unadjusted and this
is adjusted we see and these are
actually not horrible confidence
intervals a strong association between
both meth use and poly substance use and
having genotypic resistance when we
looked at phenotypic resistance the
difference here was we had a few extra
samples in here so our end was slightly
bigger and I think that's why we had a
little more power to see things we were
able to see an association with any
substance use with poly substance use
with methamphetamine with ecstasy and
with GHB now what's really interesting
though is nothing else so we looked at
all these other behaviors you know we
had these hypotheses it was the amount
of sex the amount of partner the
duration of sex nope it was just the
drug use so the mechanism for how drug
use is really increasing the likelihood
of having a resistant right virus is not
clear or whether it is sort of more of a
network factor whether it's that in
these networks of drug users you find
more resistant virus and so people who
are using drugs or having sex with other
people who are using drugs that's
another hypothesis yeah oh I'm not am I
allowed to take question or do I
it's a different way of measuring what
the resistance is just repeat the
question for the thing okay okay so i
mean it's it's not that different though
I mean it's just the real difference
between the sample actual genotypic
resistance is consider the better
measure we had a slightly bigger sample
here so I think that's why we have a
little bit more power to see a
difference so I really wouldn't place a
lot of weight in the fact that we have
the association with ecstasy here and
not here and again I think it's not
necessarily the type of drug or the drug
itself I think it's the network of drug
users that is driving this I think
people have looked for an explanation
that's more biological for
methamphetamine use and I don't believe
that there really is one necessarily at
this point so the main point though was
that and I have to say right now I'm
working on in a study in Durban in South
Africa where we're also looking at
people with resistant HIV in people who
are recruited into micro beside trial
and our HIV positive at the time of
enrollment and we'll be able to look at
this in Africa which is going to be
really interesting so we're about to
start enrolling in a study there where
we're also look at some of the
behavioral factors drug use which hasn't
been looked at a lot in South Africa and
resistance but again the fact that we
did not find any behavioral factors
associated with Matthews I thought was
pretty interesting so none of the
measures of sexual exposure were
associated and it was just the use of
drugs
so now let me tell you about the new
cohort so the new cohort is this new
study that we're doing of recently
infected men who have sex with men we
call it metro mates this one is all
based in Los Angeles and since you're
here at RDS we have a slight RDS like
design in that we're trying to reprove
partners we don't go on from the
partners so it's not a you know a
multiple chain study what we are
interested in is recruiting as many sex
partners as we can so that we can look
at things like types of virus resistance
patterns within them as well as
differences in behaviors so we are
hoping to over the course of the study
test and enroll 150 men with recent
infection and i'm proud to say in our
first year we're at 35 men so we're
doing really well and we just started up
so we're going to double our enrollment
or supposed to more than double our
moment in this next year which I think
we will easily do because we had some
down time they are enrolled in a cyber
cohort and followed for a year they're
given six coupons for sex partners and
they're given up to three months to
refer a sex partner we hope to follow
sex partners that some may have a recent
HIV some may have chronic and some may
be HIV negative and the sex partner is
then everyone who's negative that's
enrolled is again retested after year
follow-up
so we have multiple recruitment sites in
Los Angeles but one of the things that
we're finding is that it's not so much
the number of sites we have it's the
investment in the particular site so the
Los Angeles Gay and Lesbian Center is
the largest well I think they argue with
Fenway over it but they claim they are
the largest health center for gay
lesbians and bisexual people in the
world it is a very large Center and they
do a huge amount of HIV testing and they
have a lot of people who come there
regularly for testing studies that have
been done in the whole city of Los
Angeles with samples clearly identified
that most of our recent cases are in
fact found at that one research center
it is located in the heart of Hollywood
so it gets a lot of transient population
and also gets a very gay identified
population everybody there all the
negatives are because of some funding
from the health department provided NAT
testing which is to identify acute HIV
infection so those are people who have
not yet even siro converted so they test
negative but in fact have acute
infection usually they're within three
weeks of seroconversion we get referred
all the GNAT positives and then all the
new diagnosis we offered them the use of
the detuned assay so they test positive
and we see if they have recent infection
and then there's a lot of people who
come in as regular we testers and so
they actually have documented a negative
case on file at La GLC and then we're
able to see that the following test was
a positive so we've gotten a number of
that way and then we have some
physicians that have referred to us from
some of the other sites and
interestingly even though they're
referred from other sites most of those
guys decide to come to be enrolled at La
GLC and then we do this active partner
recruitment and we do offer some
reimbursement for people who have a
successfully enrolled partner and it's a
cyber cohort so people are followed up
on the web they can do their follow-up
questionnaires by their telephone we
have web enabled for telephone follow-up
questionnaires or they can use the ivr
which is an interactive voice recording
system by telephone or they can just do
it on the web and a computer and it's
pretty interesting because we thought
that the more ways we offered people to
be engaged
the better follow up we would have and I
use this interactive voice recording and
some of my other studies i'm doing a
clinical trial of rectal applicators and
we're following people we need a lot of
follow-up data and that the ivr works
great for this study no one has used our
ivr they're all doing it by the web so
that's fine because it actually is a
better method in terms of the complexity
of the data we can collect but we
thought that people would want the
option of the telephone and we're
finding it's not really of a benefit so
we're learning some things so here's the
data I pulled on the first 29 as I said
we do have 35 so one sad thing is we
only have two partners so far so we're
working on that part of that is our IRB
we had a big fight to our IRB and one of
the reasons our study started late and
we're almost a year behind us because I
had to go five times to the IRB and I
lost in that they require that I in the
invitation they tell them I should have
explained I'll show you in a bit the
people are allowed to offer partners
invite them into the study in a number
of different ways they can send an
anonymous text by their cell phone they
can send an email using the in spot
system some of you may have seen where
they get a email invitation they can
also just call them up and bring them in
so we have about four ways people can
invite partners in the study but the
invitations the IRB required says that
an HIV positive person has invited you
into the study so I fought with them
with that because these are people with
recent infection all of them with new
diagnoses and so some of these partners
are people that that they may not have
known they were positive with when they
had sex with so this is a heck of a way
to have somebody learned that you're
positive so I really felt like this
would be a barrier and I think it is so
the IRB did tell us that after a year if
that we found this was a barrier we
could come back to them so I'm ready to
do that and hopefully I can remove this
thing that says an HIV positive person
has invited you and steady and instead
would just say you've been invited to be
in a study and that should we hope help
with that one of the things though
that's interesting is I think I showed
you in the a drip sample or mean age was
think about 34 and we had quite a few
older men involved in the study what has
been interesting here are mean age is 32
but our median is 30 and if you look
here we have about fifty percent of our
sample that's under 30 now I do a lot of
studies in Los Angeles with MSM and
usually our mean age is up around 40 we
have a really hard time recruiting and
enrolling young men in any study
unfortunately I mean for the epidemic
and for the health of people out there
we are enrolling lots of younger men in
the study of recently infected man so
that suggests that there's a lot of
infection going on among younger men it
also suggests that we're actually
engaging them in a place where they want
to be engaged which is La GLC but this
this is of concern that they're younger
but as a researcher I'm happy to see
we've managed to get some younger men
because I think we don't have an update
on them we have a few older guys but
really not very many we have a nice
break down by race this is another
really interesting thing and that we're
doing here that we haven't seen as much
in our other studies is that almost half
of our sample so far are Latino we have
enrolled I think for Spanish only
speaking men and that's because it took
us a while to get all of our a cozzy
information up and going in Spanish
fully but now it is all fully enabled
and we have a staff person at La GLC
who's spent Spanish speaking and able to
do enrollments because you know it's not
just a question of your materials you
have to have a person able to engage I
should say it takes about two hours to
do each enrollment because people are
recently infected they want to have a
conversation they want to talk about it
the study coordinator both who works at
La GLC and my study coordinator are HIV
testing and counselors and part of the
reason this is work so well is because
my study manager Leo Coleman works as a
volunteer tester and counselor at La GLC
one day a week as well so he is involved
with testing and diagnosing and
counseling people all the time and he
does it as a volunteer and he's in
at the center and so when he enrolls
people in our study he's able to provide
quite a bit of counseling and support
that they need there's a lot of talking
to goes on we needed to provide that for
people who are Spanish speaking as well
so we have that we're really happy that
we have that many we know we have a big
epidemic in Los Angeles month Spanish
only MSM very hard to again reach and in
recruit and enroll them this was pretty
interesting other piece i pulled out was
that about ten percent of our sample
have been incarcerated in the last year
so who are our recently infected man
that we have now most of them have sex
with men only we have none that had sex
with just women and only six point seven
percent that were bisexual in terms of
the past year number of male partners
assuming a medium it's about what it was
in eight or a little bit less but pretty
big range past three months number of
sex partners 4.8 again that's a little
bit less than we were seeing an eight ER
but still pretty active past month
number of male sex partners about to
always using a condom during anal
intercourse about a third remember this
is a baseline when they're enrolled
again so who were their partners very
similar we have about a third of them
with a main partner and a even split
with arrest so most people fifty percent
have a main or a regular partner at
baseline and we'll see what happens over
the year the HIV status of the partner
again this is baseline remember so we'll
see if this will change but about
seventy eight percent report that their
last partner was a negative partner very
few percent reported that their last
partners they knew was a positive person
the last sex so I you I is inserted
unprotected anal intercourse and it was
about an equal percent so we talked
about zero sorting which is when people
pick a sex partner of the same HIV
status another risk reduction approach
that we think may be going on in the
community but there's not clear data on
is something called sexual positioning
which is where people pick to have a
sexual position they choose one that is
less risky for transmission so if you
are positive you're less likely to give
HIV to another person if you're
receptive right if you're the insertive
partner and we know that a lot of HIV is
in the semen right you're more likely to
transmit so if you were choosing a
position that would be less likely to
give someone else HIV you would see more
receptive intercourse going on and we
see equal numbers so we don't see a lot
of evidence at baseline for changes and
choices in sexual positioning and we'll
be following this over the year not yet
so they may change drug use at last sex
I thought this was interesting we got
more heroin than we've seen Los Angeles
has not been a big heroin city and it
was interesting because I was talking
about this with my good friend and
colleague Steve shoptaw and he got all
excited about this because he said boy
you've got younger guys and you've got
heroin use maybe this is a new trend
this is a lot so we're going to be
looking at this more carefully and
unlike in the news two days ago there
was this big story that there's more
heroin use going on in the valley and
particularly among younger men so we may
be seeing an upsurge in heroin use not
clear I think it's a little early with
just our 29 men and no comparison group
to say anything's happening but I was
surprised that it was so much more
common than our amphetamine use
and so when we looked at it we do see an
every impediment use is higher than
heroin I don't think that's a surprise
but in the past three months we see
about an equal report so that's used in
general that's not associated with sex
the other thing was associated with sex
with the last partner so that could be
higher because the last partner was not
necessarily in the past three months
injection drug use though remains only
about three and a half percent so we
have a very different epidemic I think
than what you see here locally where you
have a lot more injection drug use and a
lot more heroin use our viral load at
enrollment we have a big range of what's
going on here I think this reflects how
our recruitment happens which I'll show
you on the next slide but a lot of our
guys by the time they enroll you know we
contact them at the time but we try to
not be overly aggressive because we're
trying to be sensitive to the fact that
this is the time that they've received a
diagnosis and we are research study so
sometimes from the time that we first
are in touch with somebody until they
enroll it can be a couple weeks by that
time they may already have been in care
they may have been already getting
treatment the nice thing about doing our
study at La GLC is that they have a HIV
treatment center on site right there
it's also good for other referrals we've
done a lot of referrals for social
services help we have a scale of
measuring depression and we have what's
called a distress protocol so that
anyone who is identified as being
extremely depressed or suicidal can be
immediately referred and as soon as they
answer the questionnaire they're flagged
so far out of our 35 we've had one
person well 37 including the partners we
had one person who had some indication
of distress they weren't high distress
but enough that we made sure that they
were in touch with the counselor
immediately we are getting a lot of
sti's though so I only pulled the rectal
GC and CT here because I was really
amazed we have again our numbers are
small but twenty percent of our guys
have rectal chlamydia at baseline and
that's twenty-eight percent had either a
rectal chlamydia or gonorrhea baseline
we also have syphilis it's just as
everyone knows syphilis data it's a
little Messier to pull out so we have a
lot of people are testing positive for
our PR and syphilis but because they're
HIV positive we really work with the
county to get the correct disposition of
whether or not they're a new case so
that takes a while so here's how we get
them one really interesting thing is so
we have about fourteen percent of the
guys that are in so far that we've
identified through our detuned assay
although this week we just got two new
ones I think ones being enrolled
tomorrow and the other on monday we have
thirty five percent about ten of them
have come as gnats so those are really
cute and then we have fifty percent that
come from these previous test results so
we have a lot of people that are regular
so to speak at La GLC and remember in
order to enroll we have to be able to
see the test so either there has to be a
record of it on site or they have to
bring it to us and then we have some
doctor referrals and we do have one
person who I guess it's to at this point
who are pending so that means they've
agreed to be in the study we do one of
them was a detuned after because he
didn't have his negative test another
one the doctor had the test um these are
all waiting enrollment so of the percent
referred to us we enrolled sixty percent
now we have about twenty coupons that
are out there but only to have enrolled
and talking to my study manager he's had
quite a bit of communication with people
that were referred as partners a lot of
them say they're coming in but they
never actually show up so we have
decided that our issue is that we're not
engaging them in the study somehow so
either it's not that we're not hitting
them they're being invited but they're
not being captured so we need to work on
that piece a little bit more figuring
out how to actually engage them and
bring them in so one of the things we're
doing with that is this was our referral
card and my study staff said they looked
a little too cutesy and they didn't
think it was hip enough so
oh this is what the card looks like that
you would get I thought that was kind of
hip but apparently not so we moved to
some other imagery and that was from a
local photographer who provided some
images to us that were selected by the
study staff which we hope will be a
little more engaging and so will be up
on our website shortly we also have some
modeling which is being done which we're
excited about Steve Goudreau who some of
you may know who's from University of
Washington I'm probably marking know him
yeah he and he is working with us on
doing some modeling of this data as it
comes forward this is the model that he
sent he's interested in calculating the
probability of HIV transmission /
unprotected coital Act given the length
of time in the partnership the gender of
the partners the partnership type and
the viral load so we're excited to be
working with Steve and he's going to be
coming to UCLA to give a talk and he's
been working with us he looked at the
questionnaire and early on we made sure
that we had all the measures he wanted
here's some more of our new images and
our blood specimens which are being
saved and in our repository and we have
a new collaboration with Susan eshelman
from Johns Hopkins where she's going to
be using our specimens and we have three
different samples saved to look at some
of the new assays for identifying recent
infection one of the nice things about
our sample is that although it's not
that big we have a diversity of when
people were enrolled so it's not all
acute so we have some acute and some who
were detuned and some of the tests we
have some people that are people across
the spectrum of when they were infected
so it's a nice sample for her to work
with for this thing and as part of that
she's going to do some free phylogenetic
analysis and other things for us so
we're really excited about that
and that's pretty much it that's where
we have been and this is where we're
going so we're excited we did see in the
previous five years in this other sample
that decreases in risk behavior were not
sustained in the next five years as we
follow this new cohort we will see if
the same pattern unfortunately persists
or if we do a little better at
sustaining risk behavior sustaining
decreases in risk behavior we did see
that more main partners were acquired
over time but that risk within the
stable partner shows may increase even
if there's zero discord it it's very
hard for people with an intimate partner
to not multi use condoms to not practice
uai regardless of the HIV status we
found that the depth and detail we
corrected in terms of the behavioral
data is really necessary if you want to
study transmission dynamics and I didn't
really talk about but we have some new
methods that were using in a study to
look at the partnership level one of the
challenges and disappointments in the a
tour of data set was that we ask people
about their partners over time we asked
them to give us initials but then when
we went to do the analysis we found that
this we couldn't actually match partners
over time initials changed and people
had a hard time it was actually
impossible to figure out somebody who
said they were with the person which
actual partner that was the partner
matching was very difficult so we have a
new set of techniques that we're using
where we pre populate the data in each
of our follow-up interviews from the
previous interview on the partner
characteristics so that we don't just
ask for the initials but that we also
provide them some information so you
said this was Jim but you also said you
met him here and that he had this color
hair and that he was of that ethnicity
and so we provide some of that
information and we've done this in
another study where we're trying to see
if that helps us better match up this
partner over time so we really know
which is the ongoing partnership among
multiple partners so at the end of the
year they'll be able to match over six
partners that between baseline and over
the year to see who is continuing after
the year
and that we have this nice
multidisciplinary team I we have another
colleague that's been added this year
ray feel and wits who's from our care
clinic and as an infectious disease
doctor is looking at he got k award and
he's added some questions on pre
exposure prophylaxis and also
post-exposure prophylaxis and we did
find it in this feta we had about four
percent of our sample who said they had
done or knew someone who done I think
they had taken themselves some method of
pre exposure prophylaxis so anyone who's
involved in some of the work in the
preps trials that are going on knows
that there's a lot of prep studies a lot
of people being involved and we want to
see over time how much that impacts our
group and whether or not people are
involved in that so the also though our
community relationship has been very
important and has grown stronger over
time and that's been really the
essential part of doing this study